Karina is with us in Texas welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Marina how are you
better than I deserve what's up hey so
I've attended your financial community
classes a while back I've been working
on baby step two and three I'm kind of
in a bind on what to do with my home I
live in a mobile home the home it's
worth 35 to 40 K at the most I 72,000 on
it
good lord about I know I bought this
home with my ex-husband I was totally
against it but you know you're going to
keep it in the divorce if you were
against it so unfortunately because I
didn't want to we were going back and
forth during mediation on who was going
to keep it but because it's in my pop in
my appearance property he didn't want to
keep it I was still living in there with
my three kids at that time I wasn't
making I was making eighteen thousand
dollars a year now thank the Lord I am a
registered nurse now some a little bit
better in a position but the home is
kind of falling apart I'm really kind of
ready to get out of here and I'm still
deciding whether I should follow first
how are you gonna sell it if it's on
your parents property so I can't I've
done research because I've been living
here for about four years I've done
research it on it nobody wants to
refinance it I do like a short sell she
was totally against it and didn't very
uncooperative with me nobody I mean the
land would have to go with it wouldn't
it yes and unfortunately at the time
they kind of screwed us at the time that
we bought the home they didn't tell us
that we weren't allowed to have two
mortgages in one property we found I
found out out now no what I'm worried
about you said you didn't want to get
rid of it because it's on your parents
land do you
on the lander does your parents on it my
parents still only they still make
payments on the land your parents own
the land under the mobile home yeah so
there's two houses in the in the two
acres and so it can't be it can't be
split because of course they don't own
it so and they don't want to keep it I
don't want to keep it it's falling apart
anyways and I would really like the
there is no land with the $35,000
mortgage it's only on the mobile home
are the $70,000 mortgage on the $35,000
mobile home there's no land included in
that deal no land that's under it is in
your parents name and they are paying
payments with their regular house
payment they just let you sit it on
their property yes okay
good lord what a mess I know here's what
I would do I would call the mortgage
company on the mobile home and say I'm
not paying anymore come get it and what
if I get like foreclosure but that's a
repossession so would it be better to be
foreclosed on or file bankruptcy be
foreclosed on and in terms into buying a
home in the future so you're like
essentially I would like to buy a home
for me and my three kids you know but
that's gonna be later right now you owe
$70,000 on something that you can't sell
and it's not worth but thirty five
thousand if you could sell it and you
don't make enough to cover the
difference and so I would work with them
on a short sale again drag him back to
the table have the judge bring him back
to the table with your lawyer if you
have to but if they won't do a short
sale and he won't do a short sale
tell them you just stopped making
payments on it come get it and just live
there until they come get it eventually
they'll read it's a repossession it's
not a foreclosure because it's not
actually a piece of real estate
like a car that you sleep in okay
yeah and sorry won't affect me as much
it's gone now it's gonna affect you it's
going to affect you big-time
no it's gonna miss on your credit
big-time bankruptcy watch your words if
I let it go they may they may and then
you can settle on that and then you will
be ready to buy a house but I don't know
how is you're getting out of it unless
you just sit there and pay it off I'll
pay it off and no that's that's another
14 years it's not it's only $35,000 what
do you make do you make oh um a month
about 3,500 okay no you owe 70 you don't
know 35 yeah you're not gonna pay it off
more more okay so here's your options
all right you sit there and pay payments
that's option one while it goes down in
value and continues to fall apart option
two is you file bankruptcy in which case
they will then repossess the property
anyway or repossess the mobile home
anyway and you will have a foreclosure
and a bankruptcy or a repossession and a
bankruptcy depending on how its looked
at in Texas okay and the only difference
with the bankruptcy part is they won't
be able to chase you for the difference
I would instead I would just let them
repo it and then negotiate the balance
with them the thirty five thousand let's
say they take it for that their II
possession and they sell it for twenty
thousand that means you would owe them
fifty thousand you can probably settle
that for five or ten grand because
they're not used to collecting deficits
on mobile home repos mm-hmm people who
have fifty thousand dollars laying
around don't get repo'd mm-hmm so
they're not they're not expecting a
repossession do you have a bunch of
wealth or money you haven't told me
about in this conversation no I no I
don't I've been trying to work on the
credit cards that I left on yeah
after the divorce and then of course you
know I went I put myself through school
so when you hang up when you hang up
call them and tell them you're not
paying anymore payments and I want to
begin I want to begin a negotiation on
the short sale so you guys can come pick
this thing up or a voluntary
repossession and I want to begin a
negotiation on that and if they say we
don't do that you say well you're
getting ready to because I'm not paying
anymore payments so you're gonna have to
come together and can they just kids
what if one day I come home and they
keep my whole house and I don't and all
the stuff in it
I could happen it's not gonna happen
quickly you're probably gonna have a lot
of belligerent conversations with them
before that occurs it won't be like the
next day they show up with a big truck
they don't do that you have a lot of
conversations with them but stay in
touch with them don't ignore them in
that way they won't surprise you and
just say just let me know when you're
coming because I want you to come get it
and then when they come to earth
anything you just want your you know you
doesn't want a couple of your pictures
out of there but you don't have any
stuff you throw some stuff and parents
basement and they'll get you an
apartment as soon as you find out when
they're going to come get it it'll take
them six months to get around to it in
the meantime I can pay off my credit
cards you're not paying any house
payments okay yeah but you begin you've
already put them on notice I understand
you still owe all the money even after
they come get you and understand this
even though it's voluntary this is still
a repossession it's gonna be three four
years after this after you get all this
settled and cleaned up before you get to
go buy a house but I don't know how
you're going to get out of this three or
four years sooner than that
I think that's as soon as you're going
to earlier well I mean I guess I have to
do what I have to do and this is not
where I want to live at and don't want
to continue raising my kids here you
know one something I think
yeah it doesn't put you in a good place
20 years from today you know and 20
years from today you're still gonna be
on a dadgum mess if you don't take some
action on this and so hopefully you can
create a short-sale discussion with them
and reopen that discussion with the axe
that's your best scenario that's the
least damage to your credit but it's
still very very damaged so we're not
trying to save credit here we're trying
to save Larina